all right thanks everyone for coming out
I know there's probably a lot of other
things you want to do on your weekend a
lot of sports ball to be watched but you
also want to be a developer and I mean
you're here and that's it's a really
great first step there's a lot of people
who are not here and not doing anything
and you're actively doing it so that's
that's awesome titled this talk is how
to become a developer it's a collection
of a lot of the experiences that I've
had some of the things I think I did
right and almost everything I did wrong
as well as the experiences of some
people that I've helped mentor through
this process just recently there was a
guy who had no programming experience at
all just guys first job two months ago
and so this is really fresh on my mind
and I know the great things that Tech
has done for my life and so I'm really
really happy to share with you guys
maybe help you learn some things that
the easy way
so I'm John I'm a developer and a
consultant and I like doing things
outside of computers sometimes and this
talk is based on a series that I wrote
on my blog also called how to become a
developer and the goal here is to become
fully employed as a software developer
like that's where we want to go and so
the structure for this talk so we're
going to talk about why you might want
to become a developer what skills you
might need what kind of developer what
type of development talk about like okay
how do you actually do that and also
talk about how to get your first job
with a little bonus of how to be an
outstanding junior developer so I
imagine you have some reasons why you
wouldn't become a developer otherwise
you wouldn't be here and to me there's
really two groups and I think there are
practical reasons I think there are
personal reasons I mean the biggest
practical one just right up front I get
paced pretty good I mean if you look up
the median developer salary in your area
it's pretty good and the rate at which
you can increase that is probably higher
than about any other field out there
secondly I think there's huge market
potential
still to be had for development I mean
everything has programming in it you can
tweet from your fridge if that's the
thing that you would want to do and so
programming has given us such incredible
scale and efficiency in business like
it's here to stay and while there may be
some type of super AI that can program
itself and take over the world I mean
somebody's got to make that muzzle be
why not is anybody here who has an app
idea or a business idea that involves
technology if you do learning the
program is a great way to boost raft
those ideas I've talked to a lot of
people who have business ideas and they
are almost helplessly lost trying to
find programmers figure out what they
need like project manage it's incredibly
tough and so getting this skill set is
incredibly beneficial if you actually
want to make something with it yourself
and then lastly here I think it's
important to know that this is a known
path okay we're not finding cures for
cancer we're solving mathematical
theorems that have been unsolved for 500
years like there's a way to do this and
I don't want to underestimate the amount
of hard work that it takes because it
does take a lot of hard work but it's
not hard and I think that's a really
important distinction
it is not hard it is very doable but it
does take a lot of hard work so moving
on to some personal reasons I think some
people are surprised when they start
programming because they do it for all
those practical things and then they
find that they really just love it for
what it is and one of those reasons I
think is that programming to me is pure
creation and if you have a creative itch
it will scratch that itch a lot of
people think about oh you know
creativity is art or music or dance or
something like that but to me creativity
is anything where you have made
something that was no longer there or
that was not there before you started
there's this tweet going around recently
by a conference that said what five
words best describe programming and I
really like Ryan's answer here making
invisible robots from words like when
you program things you're commanding
bits of matter to do stuff based on
secret key words that you
like that's kind of crazy you think
about like what actually happens when
you program something to me I also like
programming because it's a domain 'less
tool programming is a very good tool and
it's great at what it does but you can
like programming and at the same time
not do it for programming like if you
like cats or you like music you can
apply programming to those things it's
real quick let's talk about some reasons
why you may not want to become a
developer and some either you don't like
computers notice I didn't say you were
not good at computers I said you do not
like them you don't like desk jobs
sitting at a desk sucks I mean it's
awful for your health and it can start
to be kind of painful over time and also
if you don't like learning new things
programming is not for you the world of
programming adapts so quickly and
changes so fast if you're not learning
you're gonna get left behind now there's
a notable exclusion there I think some
of you might be thinking oh I'm not good
at math or I'm not smart and these are
just silly things we tell ourselves
based on a teacher we had in high school
or an experience we had this is just not
true like you don't have to be smart you
are smarter enough you don't have to be
good at math there's really not that
much math in program okay so moving on
to what skills do we need you might be
surprised that I only put one thing in
this list and to me that is pure and
utter determination like you have to
know that you're gonna beat this little
piece of metal and it may kick you down
a couple times but in the end you're
going to triumph and learn this and you
can do it that's all you need
so when I started in programming I was
the first day my freshman year in
college in the computer science program
and I had done no program had absolutely
no idea and it kicked my butt
continually and it was awful and I had
no idea what I was doing every Tuesday
we got a project every Tuesday I got
depressed and I felt like I couldn't
find the help I couldn't figure it out
but I kept going and sophomore year
picked up a couple more things
junior year picked up a couple more
things again felt like okay I've got
some fun too middles you know I can make
some programs and so I finally graduated
the program
I know some things and I got my first
job as a web developer and computer
science at web development are very
different and so I felt like the ground
was ripped under I'm from underneath me
again and I was hopelessly lost because
they're just totally different concepts
but after my first job I got my second
one and I noticed that I've learned some
things and third job I learned some more
things you know I'm not getting stuck as
often I'm not getting stuck for as long
when I do get stuck and so over time you
build up these skills you build up this
knowledge and you can get there the path
is no so skills you don't need tech
savviness good at math and science a
computer science degree I'm sure there
are a lot of people to see that if you
have questions about that we can talk
about after the talk but you don't need
a computer science degree I had a friend
of mine who gave me an analogy that I
really likes and he talked about being a
welder versus a material scientist and
to me programming is like being a well
you have tools it's a skill and a craft
that you learn how to do now if you want
a computer science degree I relate that
more to material science you're
discovering new materials you're worried
about the theory of how things work now
what a material science degree help you
as a welder probably but it's not
required and so if that's something that
interests you go for that degree but
it's not something it's not a
prerequisite again it's not hard it
takes a lot of hard work there's this
blog that I found
they said this is why learning rails is
hard and they had this mind map of
skills you have to pick up and that's
kind of daunting and I don't show you
that to freak you out
but there's a lot of things that but the
thing is you don't start you know eating
the whole elephant you do it one bite at
a time
and so you pick up the first node maybe
on each of those things and maybe you
get the second one in the third and over
time you build up this really impressive
knowledge of skills because the web is
continually evolving and it's is much
there's much more to learn than there
was five ten years ago so let's talk
about what kind of developer we want to
be
development is kind of like music in
that music has genres and instruments
you might if you wanted to be a musician
you say I want to be an electric
guitarist in a rock band or I want to
play bass in a jazz trio and development
has very similar things just like music
has genres programming has types of
applications and before somebody gets
really angry in the chat this is a
simplified view there's probably like
more things are left out but just for
our sake of conversation I put them in
these four groups the first one I'm
calling websites this term might can
confuse you but to me this is when a
website is you can actually go to this
link it's still up it's just like you
would have a filing cabinet with
physical drawers a website is just
virtual documents with links to flip the
pages now we kind of colloquially use
this term for things like this which I'm
calling web apps it's a Facebook Gmail
slack and web apps are things that are
interactive so you have an account
you're submitting data the data you get
back is contextualized to you
specifically
next we have native apps you know what
these are this is your slot client for
your desktop these are the things on
your phone and the fourth one just
calling generic Internet of Things this
is more the like device sensory kind of
communication stuff so out of all of
these you want to make web apps and the
reason you want to do this is because
web apps are really at the core of all
these other things the skills you pick
up making a web app will either directly
or indirectly transfer to whatever
you're doing if you want to make a
mobile app that data is coming from
somewhere it's coming from an API it's
coming from a web app you would do
Internet of Things that's like all api's
like things talking to each other so Web
Apps is an amazing place to start don't
make websites websites are dead and you
don't want to okay so what kind of
development do we want to do in this
I've broken it kind of into two
categories first one is the front-end
this is that you interact with this is
the presentation layer it's the thing
that takes the data and then makes it in
a human readable workable
and so a front-end developer is
concerned with things like how does it
look how does it feel how do you
interact with it you probably use
technologies like HTML CSS J s react
angular ember in the contrast to that we
have the backend and for this slide I
googled back-end cloud architecture and
this is the first image I got which is
perfect but I love especially on the
side how it says the backend goes to the
front-end through internet connection
just take that in okay but seriously the
backend powers the front-end this is
stuff like servers Network requests
databases you're dealing with things
like how do you store and retrieve data
properly how do you authenticate users
use something maybe like Ruby Python
rails node and so do you want to be
front in her back-end
that's a good question the answer is yes
you want to be what we call full stack
by learning this incredible breadth of
skills you'll have everything you need
to specialize and whatever you end up
wanting to do if you saw Ryan's talk a
couple weeks ago into interviewing you
talked about t-shaped people you want to
build the top of your tea you want to
have an exposure to this wide variety of
things and over time you'd be like you
know I really like building reactive
front ends or I really like doing
database stuff and so you'll build the
you'll build the stem of your tea and
really start to specialize down in one
particular area okay that's enough
theory you guys want to know like how
like how do I actually do this so let's
talk about that first thing you need to
do is choose your tool now this can be
kind of daunting there are a lot of
programming languages out there it's a
lot of information but there really is
not a bad choice unless you didn't pick
Bulbasaur in which case
you chose poorly the thing is is any
experience is good experience when you
start there's kind of this weird
phenomena with weightlifting or if
somebody came to you and said I want to
raise him at benchpress if you told them
to go run every day a mile for four
weeks it would raise their benchpress
which makes no sense but when you're in
such an unadapted state any experience
moves you towards where you want to go
so especially in the beginning don't
worry about it just pick something do
something
it will become clear how to move and
pivot as you go along the way okay but
seriously well language just tell me a
language please before I do that have to
give you a disclaimer so asking your
programmer what language you should use
is incredibly biased like people have
chosen languages and based their entire
career around these things okay this is
like asking try not to offend people
somebody in a multi-level marketing
scheme like which should I use your
competitor the other one like you're
getting a pitch you're getting a really
strong pitch you're signing up right
there okay so if you talk to somebody
and they don't give you this disclaimer
you should not listen this person like
they are obviously still biased they
cannot see it so with all that being
said you guys are all doing HTML
Javascript CSS keep it up those are
great you need those for a back-end
language I recommend Ruby and there's a
big asterisk here that I'll talk about
later but you want to pick a language
that is stable if you're trying to learn
it and the components of the language
are changing out from under you between
versions you're not gonna have a good
time coffee angular one to two you want
to be beginner friendly C and C++ are
amazing powerful languages but they're
not beginner friendly like don't give
yourself more pain than you have to at
the beginning you want something that
has a large community okay you want
something where when you go to Google
the first 10 hits are for that language
you don't want to start learning
something and then you go to get that
job and they're like I've never heard of
that like you picked random nouns a yes
like five people use that the world
hmm you want something has a web
framework because you want to make web
apps
and you want something that has been
around for a while but it's still being
maintained and it's kind of a balance
that you have to to work but it's
important that it's continually being
improved but it's not changing so fast
that's gonna blow you out of the water
so all that being said I think all these
are good languages to choose from
someone is angry in the chat saying dot
net note or not a language we can't hear
you so stop feeling just don't pick PHP
just please pick one on the left if you
pick PHP that's fine like you
you'll learn eventually sometimes bad
experience points you towards a good
experience pick something you can make
web things with that's like the general
point okay so how you picked a language
how do we do this step one is to learn
the language itself if I said okay we're
gonna write a passionate political essay
in German we don't know any German
you're gonna have a bad time you want to
learn the grammar you want to learn the
words themselves how to put them
together then we'll talk about sentences
then we'll talk about ideas and themes
you got to learn the language yourself
or you're gonna be tripping over
yourself trying to do stuff so work
through the language and then make crud
apps this is both a description of the
quality of your apps and the type of app
itself if you didn't know crud stands
for create read update destroy okay this
is like a Facebook feed you make post
you edit posts you get your posts back
and you can delete them after you do
that you're learning the language you're
learning the tools around the language
third there's some concepts outside of
crud that you need to become familiar
with these are things like api's
database CSS and jeaious frameworks
bootstrap foundation react all that kind
of stuff
I made this doc for somebody who is
trying to go through this process and
it's it's not complete for sure but
there's some extra stuff in there if
you're interested in you want to go look
at it
and I don't think you have to do these
things these three things like in order
like do them at the same time learn some
language stuff make some crud apps
investigate something you don't know and
repeat and just keep building and
building on your knowledge
okay let's talk about getting your first
job I'm gonna quote myself being quoted
by Ryan who's quoting me originally when
I say this is probably the hardest part
in the whole process because there are a
lot of things outside of your control
with company logistics the person that's
interviewing you where you're at in the
world and where you're applying like
there's a lot of things out of your
control here but there are a lot of
things that you can do so here's some -
dues get a developer social media
presence okay this is Twitter you are
following major people in your framework
you're following the framework itself if
the framework has a new release bam
you're smashing that retweet button if I
go to the internet and I put in your
name I want to see oh this person is in
the developer world like not that
they're good or they're bad but like
they're at least in the same world that
I am if you don't have a blog or
personal site this is a great first
thing to make as a credit attend meetups
like a fiend you're already doing that
so congrats find the language that
you're doing if you're doing Python Ruby
j/s go to that meet up every single time
and talk to people
okay networking is like this big scary
word like find a nice person and go be
nice to them and talk about development
stuff that's all you have to do if you
can contribute to open source this is it
can be a little intimidating and tough
to get into but people you think like oh
how am I gonna work on Rails like the
framework that sounds insane but go
worry their documentation and fix typos
people love this if you're like hey fix
some typos this is grammatically wrong
they love that kind of stuff and it
looks good on your github if someone's
looking at your github they're not gonna
go look at what you did there's like oh
he forked rails that's amazing like he's
working in rails next step have a github
these are the big three
github twitter blog or personal site
answer questions on Stack Overflow now I
don't know a lot of people who are
looking at Stack Overflow rep as like a
metric but it's hard enough to solve
your own problems reading someone else's
description and solving their problem is
even harder so if you get good at that
when you jump into a random code base at
your new job
you'll be right at home and then lastly
and probably the most important make as
many stupid apps as possible like as
many like dozens hundreds if you can and
just absolutely dump stuff like when
Trump tweets at emails your grandma just
like literally anything you can think of
make an app out of it okay so getting
back to the first job we've done all
that stuff we're prepping what do we do
step one
talk to recruiters I got my first job
through recruiter I don't even know how
they found my email she could help me up
one day and I got my first job there so
that's great
they're recruiters that come to a lot of
these meetups like go talk to them see
you know who's hiring
what stack are they hiring for what kind
of roles are you seeing in this city do
all the normal job stuff I mean you're
making resumes and cover letters and
sending out cold emails applying on job
or just do all those extra things you
you know as the conventional job wisdom
watch Ryan's talk on interviewing
interviewing is an important part of the
process
tap your network I hate this race but go
talk to the people that you talk to at
the meetups that's really as easy as it
is like Ryan also mentioned some of my
best well all my best jobs have come
from a friend of mine telling me about
it like I had no idea it even existed
you know like hey John would be good for
this and it works this is how you're
gonna get your best job okay coming back
to the asterisk in all transparency ruby
is not big in the Oklahoma scene right
now company wise if your goal is to get
a job in Oklahoma City you're probably
better off as much as it pains me to say
doing dotnet or Java something Jas based
just because that's who's here in the
city and if you want to get your first
job it's probably you know you should be
learning the things that are here I will
say that I think the quality of jobs is
higher in tools like Ruby like if you
want to be sitting at a coffee shop
downtown with your MacBook you're not
gonna do that at like big corporation
jeaious that's just not gonna be how it
is but getting your first job is really
important it's really easy to pivot
after that and remember any experience
is good experience
okay let's talk about how to be an
outstanding junior developer so you got
your first job you're really excited
step 1 communicate really really really
really well
communication covers a multitude of sins
you're probably going to be working with
some senior developer or a boss who's
trying to coach you along the way
communicate it really well with them
does anybody remember this we're do a
little good idea bad idea for
communication it errored the page won't
load I'm stuck all these things require
the person to ask you a question again
to get more information when you're
communicating try to give them all the
information you have so they can
immediately start on your problem it'll
save time and also help from frustrating
ball team so I made a little Madlib for
us and goes like this I'm working on
blank but when I try blank blank happens
instead I've tried blank blank and blank
and looked at blank and blank example
this I'm working on the user password
password reset bug when I try to
generate a password reset link the users
token is already empty I've looked at
where the token is said and I can see
the token in the database but the token
is missing on line X if you send me this
I know what you're doing I know what
you've tried I know where you're at in
like telling me hey it's on this line we
can jump right there and start working
on the problem the next thing is to hone
your Google foo you think you can Google
but you cannot you will learn googling
Widow is a skill as much as being able
to write Ruby okay sometimes you just
want to paste that whole bad boy in
there just copy/paste BAM first hit that
works well now you want to remove
project specific info Google does not
know what undefined function who's that
pokémon its Pikachu is except that I
already googled it to make the slide so
it does so you want to remove that kind
of stuff undefined function Ruby much
better results next use a try timer of
workplaces where this is specifically
said and in other places where it's kind
of up in the air but this is the amount
of time you work on something before you
ask for help this could be 15 minutes 30
minutes an hour
whatever it is and you basically you
want to give it your best shot and try
and figure it out before you ask for
help now the important thing is let's
say you hit a problem hit a problem hit
a problem you get help you're frustrated
but you move on and then BAM a new error
what the tendency is is to go ask for
help immediately again but reset the
timer try it again
remember to relax take breaks if you
need to because the important part is
you learning how to solve your problems
not finishing the task at hand like when
you finish task a they'll give you task
B after task B is task C like that
happens forever so for you to really
grow as a developer you want to learn
how to fix your own problems
couple miscellaneous tips ask the duck
has anyone heard of rubber duck
debugging this is common in the
programming world I don't remember the
exact origin but there's a boss or
professor who put a literal rubber duck
on his desk and before people could ask
him questions they had to walk up and
audibly ask the duck the question and
what they found is that when they asked
the duck the question they figured out
the answer and there's something about
saying your question out loud organizing
it in a cohesive way where you have to
explain to someone else that trains it
uses your brain in a different way you
usually figure it out
so before we ask for help ask the duck
like if you need to literally do that
that would be great if I was a developer
trying to mentor you and I saw you had a
duck like I would love that
next take notes if you figure something
out just keep a little file open one at
my first job I literally had stickies
that I stuck to my monitor if you figure
out oh how do I add a new database
column in a migration you know just some
notes down you're gonna be referring to
these things a lot and it it's
impressive to see that when I see
somebody that has taken notes and is
really trying to learn and remember
versus someone who's just like hey how
do I do this and it's like we've done
this six times like you know got to keep
progressing
lastly fight impostor syndrome if you
don't know what this is this is this
feeling that you experience at various
points in your career where it seems
like everyone else has a figure
but you're faking it and you don't have
it and you could be feeling that right
now like
non-developer like how do I do this and
this is absolute garbage I love this
picture because it shows that we all
have different experiences and skills
and we overlap but nobody just like
completely bulldozes over you like you
have valuable experience especially
coming outside of the programming world
if you can bring to whatever you're
doing so lastly I want to talk about
closing the junior/senior gap and a lot
of people when they think about you know
these loose terms of junior and senior
developer they think oh the senior has
all this knowledge they have all this
experience where they just know the
answer like they see something as boom
they know it and that is true to an
extent like you will gain knowledge but
the thing that really separates someone
who's like I think a great developer and
a good one is that great developers have
a problem-solving system they have honed
and polished this system to where yes
they may get stuck but they are so fast
at figuring out because they go straight
to the problem they researched the
implement and it works and so I'm gonna
give you five debugging tips you can use
this from day one all the way throughout
your career number one when you run into
a problem don't thrash your code most
people when they run into a problem they
just go crazy changing stuff and you
introduce like five new problems on top
of the problem you already have so don't
thrash your code use your system number
to read the error message okay no but
actually read it I've seen a lot of
people they're like oh no that's garbage
it's like computer barf not gonna read
it like that is computer barf and part
of that is just like nonsense but part
of this is vitally helpful tells you
what the air is and the exact file and
line that it happens so instead of just
going crazy in your code go straight to
that line it'll save you so much time
next don't waste time on the impossible
or at least the improbable there is a
chance although it is extremely low the
you will run into a core framework or
language bug or a browser bug or an oh
little bug but the chances are you did
something wrong so I see a lot of people
who they're like well I set this thing
to true but it's still false but I set
it to true and their mind is just like
blown like how could it not be true and
so instead of saying how could this not
be true say how could this not be true
thinking emoji like engage your brain
and start to work through the system of
like okay it's not true accepted how do
I make it true this next tip if you took
anything away you take one thing this
would be it when in doubt print more out
I do this every single day print stuff
in your code this shows you line by line
what's happening what's the data coming
in what's the data going out countless
time somebody will be like it just
doesn't work doesn't work doesn't work
I'm like okay print the print the first
line here functioned they're like oh
it's not being called you spend so much
time and it's like your functions not
even being called so like see exactly
where you are what's the data going in
what's the data going out this will
drastically speed up what you're doing
okay lastly take it one step at a time
even to this day if I'm gonna implement
say a new feature in a web app I will
set up the route in the template and
print the word hi to myself and I will
see that I can see the word high on the
screen before I do anything else there's
this tendency to like just going crazy
in the code I did this in school all the
time and get a project and not three
hours just going hard plug alright time
to run fails it's like well what did I
expect
I type for three hours and didn't check
anything take it one step at a time and
print it out trust me print it out so to
wrap up
I know if throwing a lot of things that
you but I hope there's some direction
and some belief you can get that you can
do this lots of people have done it I
did it and struggle terribly hopefully
you can learn from my mistakes but in
the end you just got to believe you can
do it and just get after it every day a
couple of references for you if you want
to try Ruby that's a great link the
rails tutorial that I mentioned like
every rails developer in the
world has gone through that book and
it's amazing even if you don't end up
with choosing rails like that's probably
still good book to go through I still
link to my extras doc and then to Ryan's
interview if you didn't see that talk
I'm at John Moses Minh about everywhere
on the web if you want to talk the happy
to talk with you help you in any way I
can and with that have some questions
yes
mm-hmm
it's a good question so you're saying
you've learned Ruby but there's not a
great scene here for that yet how like
what should you do next I would say I
think picking another language is
probably good I think you'll find that a
lot of the things you didn't read people
directly transfer like the syntax is a
little different but the concepts are
there like I said in the talk I don't
think it really matters which one you
pick I would talk to recruiters and see
you know who's hiring whether that's net
or something javascript-based or
whatever
in the meantime so let me ask what was
what do you think the problem was in
finding a Ruby job where you're not able
to find enough things to apply to or you
weren't able to get far enough
gotcha yeah
Oklahoma is or at least Oklahoma City is
very dotnet syndrich so I don't think
that is a bad career move like you're
not gonna regret learning net to work
here I think you can also depend upon
your level experience like you could
keep making things like maybe there's a
job out there that you could get if you
had a little more exposure a little more
experience but picking up something like
JavaScript whether that's angular
angular or react or something like that
like that's gonna directly translate
into any other job you do so I don't
think there's a bad option I think you
have to kind of pick something but
definitely go talk to the recruiters and
see just what's out there
anyone else yes ready for the first job
or I don't think you ever hit a point
where you're like yeah now I'm ready I
think it's just about continually
growing and overtime like things will
line up because the job thing is tough
because it like I said there's so many
things outside of your control I think
you just have to it's kind of like when
people say as I quote go the
hard-working people are always lucky or
something like that it's like you know
like oh they got such a big break that's
like really they were just you know on
their grind for like two years and they
were just getting after it
and so it's like oh they got this
amazing thing I think there's definitely
kind of a checklist of like can I make
credit app do I know what api's are have
I made them you know can I do some
sequel stuff if I used all the major
JavaScript CSS frameworks there's some
checkboxes like that but I really think
it's just about continuing to grow until
something lines up or on the other kind
of flipside is and it sounds bad but
like the stronger your network is the
more people you know like if I know you
really well and I'm working in a place
where it's like hey we could really you
know we could take on another developer
right now like those people are gonna be
at the top of my list to pull in yes
the question is have it's a good
question have I ever
based on my computer science background
basically have I ever like directly use
that in a job I got so close to using it
I'm dead serious
one time I got so close I was like yes I
got this I don't remember what it was
and then I was like actually there's a
better way to do this and I scrapped it
so like the answer is basically no you
want to go work for Amazon Google
Facebook where they're solving like
crazy problems yet you probably need
computer science but the average
programming gig no honestly you don't
yeah so like the u.s. specifically have
you ever used for Kuragin and it's like
I mean like you said recursion and loops
can generally be kind of interchanged
but so here's another great thing I
should mention there's this there's so
many resources online now I think
Stanford has an online class where they
basically they put their CS class online
and so if you need to learn about so you
don't you learn about those things but
if you're like oh I don't really
understand recursion there's tons of
stuff online to go see and there's also
a book it costs it costs money but it's
called the imposter handbook it's by a
guy named Rob Connery who basically
breaks down all the important CS
concepts you know how do you make state
machines and how to compilers work and
all this kind of stuff which is really
not like I said very applicable but if
that is interesting to you like go get
that book and and work through it
there's a lot of I think the big overall
point is there's a lot of resources out
there bed weren't there five years ago
definitely weren't there ten years ago
it's where like just the time and money
it takes to go through that degree it's
not the fastest path to get where you
want to go if you want to do development
I guess is the overall point good
question
anybody else
all right thank you
[Applause]